KOREA.
WE'LL SHOW YOU THIS HISTORIC
TAPE.
FIRST, IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
VERY IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
AS WE SPEAK, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS POURING
THROUGH 49 BRAND NEW ADDITIONAL
PAGES OF NEWLY UNCOVERED TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER, THESE
MESSAGES WERE A PART OF THE SIX
MONTHS OF MISSING TEXTS THAT
SOMEHOW, WELL, WERE LOST BECAUSE
OF AN ALLEGED TECHNICAL ISSUE
WITH THE SAMSUNG PHONES.
FOX NEWS CAN CONFIRM THAT MANY
OF THESE UNEARTHED TEXTS HAVE
INCOMPLETE INFORMATION.
SARAH CARTER JOINS US WITH THE
NEW INFORMATION.
WE KNOW IN PREVIOUS TEXTS, PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE CONSTANTLY
TRASHING PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLING
HIM AND IDIOT, A MENACE A LONE
SOME HUMAN BEING AND SAID F
TRUMP.
PRIOR TO ELECTION DAY, PETER
STRZOK MENTIONED AN INSURANCE
POLICY THAT WAS PROPOSED TO
ANDREW McCABE IF TRUMP SHOULD
ASSUME OFFICE.
NOW, "I WANT TO BELIEVE THE PATH
THAT YOU THREW OUT FOR
CONSIDERATION IN ANDY'S OFFICE,
THAT THERE'S NO WAY HE GETS
ELECTED, BUT I'M AFRAID WE CAN'T
TAKE THAT RISK.
IT'S LIKE AN INSURANCE POLICY IN
THE UNLIKELY EVENT BEFORE YOU
DIE BEFORE YOUR 40."
WHAT DID THAT MEAN?
AND THE LETTER FROM HARRY REID
URGING TRUMP TO OPEN A COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION.
AFTER THAT LETTER BECAME PUBLIC,
PETER STRZOK TEXTED LISA PAGE A
NEW YORK TO A "NEW YORK TIMES"
ARTICLE WRITING "HERE WE GO."
NOW WE'RE LITERALLY ACTIVELY --
THEY WERE ACTIVELY ROOTING FOR
THE PRESIDENT'S DEMISE OR WHAT
IS THE INSURANCE POLICY?
WHAT IS THE INSURANCE PLAN?
WAS IT TO DRAG THE PRESIDENT
THROUGH THE MUD?
EITHER WAY, IT'S NOT A GOOD LOOK
FOR TWO PEOPLE THAT WERE TAPPED
BY ROBERT MUELLER FOR KEY ROLES
IN THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION WITCH HUNT.
EVEN WORSE, THIS DOES CRITICAL
DAMAGE TO THE REPUTATION OF OUR
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
EVERY ONE OF US, EVERY AMERICAN
NEEDS TO BE CONCERNED.
ALL RIGHT.
BREAKING TONIGHT, JAMES COMEY
WAS GRILLED BY BRET BAIER HERE
ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
HE'S NOW CLAIMING THAT THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
UNVERIFIED DOSSIER THAT MADE UP
THE BULK OF THE FISA APPLICATION
HE SAID DID NOT MAKE UP THE BULK
OF THE FISA APPLICATION EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE TWO CONGRESSIONAL
MEMOS THAT CONTRADICT WHAT JAMES
COMEY SAID JUST A FEW MINUTES
AGO.
A FEW HOURS AGO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU CALLED THE DOSSIER
UNVERIFIED, SALACIOUS.
WHY DID YOU USE THAT TO THE FISA
COURT TO ASK FOR SURVEILLANCE
FOR CARTER PAGE?
YOU USED IT AND LED WITH IT, A
BULK OF THAT FISA APPLICATION
DEALS WITH THAT DOSSIER?
>> THAT'S NOT MY RECOLLECTION.
MY RECOLLECTION IS IT WAS A PART
OF A BROADER MOSAIC OF FACTS LED
BEFORE THE JUDGE TO GET THE FISA
WARRANT.
>> THERE WAS MORE THAN THE
DOSSIER?
>> MY RECOLLECTION IS THERE WAS
AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF MATERIAL
AND WHY THERE WAS PROBABLE CAGE
THAT PAGE WAS A FOREIGN AGENT.
THE DOSSIER WAS PART OF IT OR
NOT PART OF IT OR A CRITICAL
PART OF IT.
>> I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
BELIEVING THAT.
THIS IS ALMOST UNBELIEVABLE.
JAMES COMEY STILL CLAIMING NOT
TO KNOW WHO PAID FOR HILLARY'S
DIRTY DOSSIER WITH RUSSIAN LIES
AND PROPAGANDA THAT WAS PUT
TOGETHER BY A FOREIGN NATIONAL.
INCLUDING RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
LIES.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> WHEN DID YOU LEARN THAT THE
DNC AND HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN
WORK?
>> I STILL DON'T KNOW THAT FOR A
FACT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> I HAVE ONLY SEEN IT IN THE
MEDIA.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHICH DEMOCRATS
FUNDED -- I KNEW IT WAS FUNDED
FIRST BY REPUBLICANS --
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> SORRY?
THE DOSSIER THAT CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WORKED ON WAS FUNDED BY
REPUBLICANS?
>> MY UNDERSTANDING HIS WORK
STARTED AS OPPO RUSH FUNDED BY
REPUBLICANS --
>> SO FREE BEACON SAID THEY HAD
GLEN SIMPSON AND FUSION GPS ON A
RETAINEDER BUT THEY DIDN'T FIND
IT.
IT WAS INITIATED BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> MY UNDERSTANDING IS STEELE
WAS HIRED -- WAS FIRST FUNDED BY
REPUBLICANS -- THE IMPORTANT
THING IS, PICKED UP BY DEMOCRATS
OPPOSED TO BY DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: THIS IS MIND BLOWING.
THEY NEVER VERIFIED IT.
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHO FUNDED IT?
REALLY?
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS NOT
BROUGHT IN UNTIL HILLARY TOOK
OVER.
THE FUSION GPS DEEP DIVE INTO
DONALD TRUMP.
EARLIER TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
CALLED IN TO "FOX AND FRIENDS"
AND SOUNDED OFF RIGHTLY SO ON
JAMES COMEY.
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> COMEY IS A LEAKER AND HE'S A
LIAR.
AND NOT ONLY ON THIS STUFF, BUT
HE'S BEEN LEAKING FOR YEARS.
HE'S PROBABLY BEEN USING HIS
FRIEND, THE SO-CALLED PROFESSOR
THAT TURNS OUT TO HAVE FBI
CLEARANCE, WHICH HE NEVER SAID,
HE EVEN LIED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
HE NEVER SAID THAT IN CONGRESS.
HE SAID HE GAVE IT TO A FRIEND.
HE GAVE IT TO A FRIEND TO LEAK,
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
IT'S ALL CLASSIFIED.
TOTALLY CLASSIFIED.
SO HE ILLEGALLY -- HE DID AN
ILLEGAL ACT AND HE SAID IT
HIMSELF IN ORDER TO GET A
SPECIAL COUNSEL AGAINST ME.
SO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL -- BY THE
WAY, AND INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
AND EVERYBODY ELSE HAS FOUND NO
COLLUSION.
NOBODY UNCLASSIFIED THEM.
THOSE MEMOS WERE ABOUT ME AND
THEY'RE PHONY MEMOS.
HE DIDN'T WRITE THEM.
HE PUT PHONY STUFF.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT IS
CORRECT AND THE PRESIDENT ALSO
SLAMMING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND MUELLER'S PARTISAN
WITCH HUNT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I ANSWER THIS ALL THE TIME.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE THIS WITCH HUNT GOING ON
WITH PEOPLE IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT SHOULDN'T BE
THERE, THEY HAVE A WITCH HUNT
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES GOING ON.
I'VE TAKEN THE POSITION AND I
DON'T HAVE TO TAKE THIS POSITION
AND MAYBE I'LL CHANGE, THAT I
WILL NOT BE INVOLVED WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
I WILL WAIT TILL THIS IS OVER.
IT'S A TOTAL -- IT'S ALL LIES
AND IT'S A HORRIBLE THING THAT
IS GOING ON.
I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED IN MY
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
IT'S GOING ON AND I THINK YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND THIS, I HAVE DECIDED
I WON'T BE INVOLVED.
I MAY CHANGE MY MIND AT SOME
POINT.
WHAT IS GOING ON IS A DISGRACE.
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE DISGRACE.
AND BY THE WAY, THE ONLY
COLLUSION IS THE COLLUSION WITH
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE RUSSIANS.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING
ON THERE.
THEY WOULDN'T EVEN GIVE THEIR
SERVER THE DNC, THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE WOULDN'T GIVE
THEIR SERVER TO THE FBI.
WHAT KIND OF AN FBI?
THEY BREAK DOWN DOORS FOR PAUL
MANAFORT EARLY IN THE MORNING.